okay hello there welcome to another week
of science and technology q a for kids
and others
um i'm a little busy today because i'm
getting ready for a grand
centenary tomorrow no not tomorrow
monday actually of the invention of
things called combinators which were
an early precursor of what we now know
of as universal computation
uh not well-known but very important in
the historical development
of what we now know of as the idea of
computation anyway i'm
trying to uh get ready some material
for an event uh for that day but
let's um start off we have some
questions left over from last time we
have one from shuri why do people refer
to the internet as the world wide web
isn't what's the relationship between
networks and websites and all those
kinds of things
all right we can try and talk about that
so there's really several
layers of what
the internet and the web and so on are
in the end the internet
is a network that connects a whole bunch
of computers together
one of the things that a lot of those
computers do
is to provide websites and you connect
two websites through the internet
but the web itself is is that connection
of websites
not the underlying connections between
computers
so we can talk a little bit about how
the web works how the internet works and
so on
so you'll notice when you when you type
in
the uh address for a website it usually
starts
http or https
and then it has a bunch of other other
stuff in it
what that http stands for it says it
stands for hypertext
transfer protocol trans transfer
transport i'm not sure
protocol um the
um and that is telling
uh that that is a way of saying
this piece of information that's
available from this computer
is going to be transported in this form
so that it can be read by programs that
can read that format
and so the for http
the main kind of program that reads that
format is a web browser
so a web browser if if you look at
what is coming from uh to your computer
when you connect to a website
you'll see all kinds of data that data
is in that
the format it's it's being transported
in http form and
most of the content is in html which is
the standard basic language of web pages
and then what your web browser does is
to take that data that's in
being transported in http form and
show it as a website on your computer
but so what's happening underneath is
there's uh what has to happen is that
the data has to be transferred that's
the job of the internet
the web is the parts of that data
that are in a form that can be consumed
by things like web browsers
so for example there are other prefixes
other than http
there are other prefixes that you can
see there that are intended for programs
other than web browsers for example
another one is some ftp
that was an older type of way of
transferring data
over the internet it's ftp stands for
file transfer protocol
just a way of taking a whole file and
sending it over the internet
um there are other things for example we
have one wstp it's a transfer protocol
for symbolic expressions in world from
language that's another thing that you
could see
uh in front of um the ht instead of http
as the thing describing what kind of
data you're going to get
from a computer if you connect to that
uh place now the thing that
the the the thing that um uh
is the specification of where you're
going usually called the url
is is the thing that kind of tells tells
your computer
kind of where to look for information on
the internet
um and uh oh boy this gets kind of
complicated
so there are things with urls there are
also things called uris which are a bit
of a generalization of urls
but let's talk a little bit about urls
and what they mean and how that all
works and so on
um and and essentially what's what's
happening is
that url that says something like i
don't know
um www.wolfram.com
that url is something that your computer
can use to uh that
that's a a way to specify a
way to specify the the the computer that
can deliver
certain kinds of information to your
computer so i'm pausing a little bit
because actually the whole story is
really quite complicated
um and that that address
could actually not just be one computer
it could be something which is
which is where the sort of the
information associated with that but
with that address is delivered by
multiple computers
all right but let's start off with with
a little bit more of the of the basics
of um uh let's talk first of all about
the internet what it is and a bit about
how it works
so the internet has a big collection of
computers probably by now a billion of
them
maybe even more it grew out of a thing
called the opennet
that people like me used to use back in
the 1970s actually
the arpanet was a connection at those
time in those times of like 256
computers
and in those days you would refer to a
computer
on the arpanet just by a number like my
favorite computer was one called 236
which was a computer at mit um and you
would uh
basically connect to the opennet
say what number of computer you wanted
to get to and then
you would be able to start sending
information to that computer getting
information back from that computer
one of the big innovations of the of the
arpanet became the internet
was the question of sort of how the
information was sent
from you to that computer and the idea
was
that there were multiple paths by which
it could sent it
would get sent it would go from your
computer to another computer to another
computer to another computer
and eventually get to the computer you
wanted to communicate with
and the idea was that even if one path
one route
to get from you to the computer you
wanted to get to was somehow broken
you could still uh there it would be the
the system
would automatically figure out another
route which would allow you to get to
the computer you wanted to get to so
that it made for a network that was
uh wouldn't be able to be taken down by
just one computer failing and so on
now the the way of calculating what was
the best route was kind of tricky
and still kind of tricky um and there's
a lot of kind of black magic
associated with with working out those
best routes there was a time
long long ago now when a computer i
think was in hawaii
uh really confused what was then the
early
internet i think um by by
uh sort of broadcasting to the world
when you send data through me
the data will arrive in negative time
and so all the other computers said well
that's a really great place to send our
data through
so everybody started routing data
through this computer in hawaii needless
to say it got overloaded
and the the internet sort of went down
it was a long time ago
but that's the kind of problem that can
happen when you're saying there are
these multiple routes through the
internet
and you're trying to figure out which is
the best one and so on
okay well what happens today well
today computers on the internet are
specified by
addresses so-called ip addresses um
and they would be things that the the
the original version is ipv4
which has these four blocks of numbers
and so different companies and countries
will get particular blocks assigned to
them so they're
things like a class a network says
you're you're you're going to get
everything that's after that first block
of numbers class b network everything
after the second block of numbers
so for example my company uh well from
research
um we were very early on the internet
probably around 1987 or so
maybe 1986 even um and so we got to sign
the class b block 140.177.
everything after 140.177.10.20 or
something
everything after 140.177 that's that's
part of our
section of the internet um it's kind of
a funny thing because
because because we were early to the
internet our block of internet space
is bigger than some countries and so on
but uh that's that's just the way these
things tend to work
anyway so so every computer that's sort
of exposed to the internet gets one of
these addresses
the world kind of ran out of ipv4
addresses so that's why ipv6
is really the thing that's coming in and
that has a longer address block
so more computers can be separately
connected to the internet
so okay so you've got this ip address
and the question then is uh what is the
relationship between that ip address
and the thing you type in like
wolfram.com for example
well so what has to happen is something
has to translate
from you typing in wilfred.com to
uh your computer somehow knowing that
that means you're trying to send
information or get information
from some computer in the
140.177.whatever.whatever
uh internet address okay so first sort
of
complicated thing that happens is uh
their so-called dns lookup which is how
do you associate wolfman.com
with uh 140.177
and so on and so what happens is there
are
uh well there are a whole collection of
layers
that do this but actually there are two
sort of things that have to happen
one is how do you associate woven.com
with 140.177 etc
and second how do you actually get from
your computer
to a computer that is serving
that that is at the the internet address
and that's serving the content
that comes from orphan.com how do what
is the
what is the route that you will go so
there's this notion of first of all how
does the dns lookup work
how do you get the routing table that
tells you what the right route is and so
on
and the way it's done is there's sort of
layers of of
of information so for example if you've
been to orphan.com recently
you might have cached stored on your
computer
the information oh that's 140.177.
whatever
but maybe maybe you didn't go there
recently well then your computer won't
know it
but a computer that your computer is
connected to does know
and then a computer that that computer
is connected to does know and eventually
you kind of peel backwards
and for example the dot-com top-level
domain
you can ultimately look everything up
that comes from the dot-com
top-level domain through the
registries that work that tell you what
the actual raw ip address associated
with those with anything in that domain
is
now ultimately the um as a question of
sort of what's the what's the end of the
line where is the information about
what the uh how domains are connected to
internet addresses was that ultimately
stored
the world has i think it's 13 root name
servers
which are computers distributed around
different parts of the world
um that contain sort of the ultimate uh
records
um at any given time of what
um of what the association of domain
names with international addresses
actually is
when you change one of those things it
uh that that change has to sort of
propagate
around the world and propagate to all
these tables it usually takes only 15
minutes or so i think these days
to do that propagation but that's sort
of what happens if you if you changed
that association between
the the domain name and the ip address
so another question is how do you how do
you route
um how do you actually get to a
particular ip address and this is where
things get quite quite complicated and
there's
all these things um uh bgp
routing and all kinds of other elaborate
kinds of issues about sort of what is
the best route to get from here to there
how does it change what uh servers
decide
how the routes work and so on and it
gets even more complicated because
uh in the end your information is going
to get routed through things like fiber
optic cables
that actually are the the raw hardware
that implements the internet
and different companies own different
cables and different companies kind of
exchange information
differently with other companies and so
it's like well i'm
i'm trying to get to this att um
uh kind of uh network but and there's
i'm i'm using some
i'm on some verizon network how does the
verizon network connect to the at t
network how does that all work and
ultimately there are
it's a pretty complicated system of all
these routers and so on
and figuring out what is the fastest way
for your data to get to the particular
computer that you're trying to get it to
is a complicated thing and it's
something which can change over time
it's something where there are different
algorithms for figuring it out and so on
at any given time you can find out how
your computer is routing data to a given
computer
uh there's a low level command on unix
systems called traceroute
and you just type in traceroute and then
the name of some domain or an ip address
and it'll show you
all the hops that it's going through so
it'll say your data went from your
computer to that computer that's
down the street to that computer that's
your internet service provider
your internet service provider then
sends the data to
some other computer and eventually if
it's going across the pacific ocean or
something it'll send it to some
computer that's connected to the fiber
that goes across the pacific ocean
gets to the other side goes to some
other internet service provider et
cetera et cetera et cetera and
you'll typically see uh maybe 10 hops or
something will be a not untypical
thing to see and each one of those hops
takes a certain amount of time
so maybe the the total time for your
data to get from your computer to
some computer on the other side of the
world might be 200 milliseconds
and it's going through that's a ten two
tenths of a second
um and uh uh it's going through a bunch
of other computers and each time it goes
through another computer
it might take another hundredth of a
second or something to
to get transmitted and so on so that's
kind of how the low-level part of um
uh of the internet works now the
question is
um how does for example a website work
well when you go to a website what's
happening is
you're you type in wolfram.com your web
browser
uh is going to send that is it
needs to send a request to
the computer that is serving the website
that is wolfram.com
okay so essentially what's happening in
this
http protocol that's the thing that is
used for
for websites what's happening is
your web browser is basically saying to
the computer that is hosting the website
it says i want the next i want a page to
the website
and the computer that's hosting the
website then responds and says
okay here's a bunch of data that
represents that website
so what's happening is your web browser
is sending a request
usually it might be a so-called get
request
um that is is a request it's a bunch of
data you can actually see them there
they're just text and it'll just say get
this page and so on um and it will send
that data over the internet to the
address
that it got by translating the name
www.open.com or something
to an ip address it'll send it to that
ip address
okay what is it what happens when it
gets to that ip address
well at that ip address there's a
computer whose sole
well who's whose main function is to
just watch for requests coming in
and every time it sees a request coming
in that says you know get web page such
and such
it'll say okay here it is um so
that computer will see a stream of those
requests so to a big website
there might be uh thousands tens of
thousands of those requests
every second um that are coming in where
web browsers from all over the world are
saying i want this web page i want that
web page i want that web page
and then that web server is responding
by saying okay here
here's the data associated with that web
page your web browser then receives that
data
and then renders it and that's the web
page that you see
now again things get even more
complicated because
when you say i want to get the web page
i don't know i want to go to wolfman
alpha.com okay
turns out there's more than one computer
that can
uh sort of that can give you the data of
wolfman alpha.com
there are multiple usually called colos
co-location facilities
um there are multiple colos that contain
computers that
can uh give you wolframalpha.com
so when you actually send that request
out
something has to decide which of those
computers you're actually going to go to
ultimately you have to it has to be go
from
the wolframalpha.com domain name to an
ip address
each of those computers in the end will
have an ip address
there's a bunch of tricky stuff there's
a idea called geodns
which is something where you're actually
looking at what is the geolocation of
the computer
that the request is coming from and make
sure it's
you're sending the request to the uh
sort of
geographically or at least internet
closest
uh colo so that the request so that the
data can come back as quickly as
possible
now again something else that happens
it's again kind of complicated
is um usually when you request a web
page
um you you're you're just saying i want
the web page from such and such a
company and it's
it has some web server and so on and
your requests will have to go all the
way to that company to get the data back
but actually that's not the most
efficient thing to do because assume
that data
doesn't really change much or doesn't
change at all then and assume many many
people request it
then it makes more sense to store
versions of that data closer to people's
computers
not all the way at whatever company
originally was making that website
so there are all kinds of networks
content delivery networks and so on
that uh store that that provide
large numbers of computers tens of
thousands of computers around the world
that will store copies of
sort of web pages fragments of web pages
things like that
um images movies things of that kind
and those are uh that's that's often
when you request one of these things you
won't get
the data all the way from the original
web server that was sort of the original
producer
of that data it will instead be one of
these uh
caching servers that is uh uh that's
easier for your computer to get to
and faster for you to get to so i mean
there's there's
even vastly more complexity than this to
the whole way that the internet works
um it's sort of remarkable sometimes
that the system does work as
as comparably well as it does people uh
maybe a decade or two ago people were
very concerned about the idea of things
like
internet storms where somehow all of the
different routing of packets and data
and so on
would all get confused uh like that
incident i mentioned about the computer
in hawaii that said it took a negative
time to route data through it
but other things that would just be a
consequence of the dynamics of data
routing around the internet um that
somehow there would be these
these moments when the internet would
would dramatically slow down
um just because of some dynamics of the
way that all this
routing of data works and that has
become less of a problem it seems over
over time um and uh possibly just
because the communication links on the
internet have gotten faster
the router computers have gotten faster
and so on
or possibly uh because uh and there's
something that gradually evolves the
actual protocol
for deciding which route you take on the
internet although
as i say that's a little bit of black
magic um that typically goes into
deciding those kinds of things and
typically the different
uh um uh internet service providers and
so on and different different setups for
how you're connected to the internet
will have different detailed ways that
that's treated
so okay that was a that was a very rough
um
description of um sort of how the
internet and the and the web
work and fit together all right very
different questions here let's see
a question from desi durie
is there a philosopher who developed a
system which is close to
my perspective right now you know i'm
embarrassed to say don't really know
um it's hard enough to understand
what kind of scientists conclude and say
about things
but usually when you have a science
theory you can kind of boil it down to
and it's this particular thing it's a
particular idea
with philosophers i think it's it's it's
less plausible that one can boil things
down to
sort of one particular idea it tends to
be a whole kind of framework
for thinking about things and also
you know when you look at science for
example
it's a question do i understand this
framework well
if i can write a program that implements
the framework and i can kind of compute
things from it
then i feel like i more or less
understand the framework with
philosophers it's like do i understand
what uh you know emmanuel kant had to
say about this or that thing
i don't know i could talk to somebody
about it they'd tell me well you haven't
got it quite right
you try and actually read it it's like
what does the sentence mean i don't
really quite know
there isn't sort of this translation to
kind of computational language that's
possible
in more sort of direct science kinds of
things i mean a good case in point is
gottfried leibniz
philosophy who lived in the late 1600s
who i've studied a certain amount
um and who for example was very
interested in many of the kinds of
questions that i've been interested in
about things like uh uh is there a sort
of
uh ca he talked about a characteristic
universe solace a
a universal language for describing
things in the world
a philosophical language as it was
sometimes called back then
a way of sort of turning into what we
would now
sort of a symbolic representation of
things in the world
that had some kind of precise in a sense
mathematical character
it's very much the same kind of thing
that i've spent uh many decades trying
to do with our computational language
to find a way to represent sort of in a
precise computational form
things in the world anyway gottfried
leibniz wanted to do that he made quite
a bit of progress doing that
he also did things like he was one of
the inventors of calculus
and he also thought a bunch about
mathematical notation and he also
talked about things called monads and he
had this whole theory
of mononadology and i regularly get
email from people saying
i think your theory is related to
monadology
um and you know i've wondered this for
years
but i just don't really know because i
can look at what leibniz wrote and i
have done so
and i find it incomprehensible now
you know it was written in latin i can
just about probably pick my way through
his latin
but i'm usually reading a translation so
that's you know
step number one away but more important
the way people talked about things and
the way people thought about things in
the 1600s is really different
from the way we talk about them today i
mean he wasn't talking about
oh we can turn everything into a
symbolic language
where we can compute this or that he
didn't have this notion
of you know this general idea of
computation he he did have the idea
that you could make in fact he himself
spent many years building kind of a
mechanical computer
that uh computed um things like addition
and subtraction and multiplication and
so on
but he didn't have the modern conception
of computation he didn't have all of the
sort of modern framework of ideas that
we have now
so it's really super difficult to
translate
from the way that i think about things
today to what he was talking about and
to figure out
was he really saying this wasn't he
saying this i don't know
um i think that the same uh you know as
you get closer to the present day
it becomes a little bit easier
potentially to understand what
philosophers are written
but i have to say for me it's very
difficult to know whether i really
kind of nailed down this is what the
person really meant
when they said this and uh
it doesn't mean that the ideas aren't
interesting and that uh it isn't worth
reading what they said and often
often and i think it's a characteristic
of philosophers uh
it's more the questions you ask
necessarily than the answers you get
that um uh are what's important i mean i
i am uh it so happens my my mother was a
philosophy professor
um in oxford and um uh so i i would run
into an
uh at a time actually when oxford was
sort of the kind of world center for
philosophy
um and so when i was a kid i would would
run into all these philosophers and so
on and
and uh sometimes i would sort of try and
debate them on topics of science
i'm sure it was quite entertaining i was
was when i was like 10 years old
or younger and so on um and
i know from my own experiences with
modern 10 year olds and so on
that uh it can be really interesting to
to have those kinds of discussions
um but in any case the um uh
i think one of the things that i always
used to uh kind of
um uh give the kind of philosophy
profession a hard time about
is look you know you're still talking
about what plato said
you haven't answered that was 2000 years
ago and you don't have answers
you're still just debating was he right
when he said this wasn't he right when
he said this
you know this is a subject where you've
been having
discussions for 2000 years it's like
come on let's get actual conclusions
and you know in a sense science has
mostly been very different from that
science has had
this notion of progressive conclusions
and progressive sort of layers of
progress being made
now so the interesting thing with
philosophy today
is that some of the things that have
been matters of philosophy and ethics
and other places
they actually have to turn into actual
pieces of computer code
implementing you know ethics for
artificial intelligence or something
like this
so all of those discussions that
philosophers might have had for 2000
years
you've got to come up with some answer
because in the end
you know that self-driving car has to
make an ethics decision
and it can't go back and consult
spinoza's ethics
you know treatise and have a debate
about it
it's got uh you know uh five
milliseconds to decide whether to do
this or that
and in the end you've got to sort of
turn philosophy into a code
and that's a process that is a very
interesting process that's sort of a
a thing that that needs to be thought
about today and i think it's a general
feature of philosophy
that it's provided these sort of
frameworks for thinking about things and
then at some moment
something maybe it's science maybe it's
law
maybe it's something else has to take
that framework and do something definite
with it
the existence of that philosophical
framework is is very important
um but in the end somebody's got to take
it and and make a definite decision on
the basis of it
and i think we're about to see that
happen uh for lots of
other areas of philosophy i mean i know
if you look at different areas of
philosophy you know things like
epistemology
theory of knowledge ontology the sort of
theory of what's what exists in the
world and so on
and uh or something like ethics
all of these things have very sort of
concrete character
when it comes to what we have to do with
in computation i mean for example
in a lot of what i've tried to do in
computational language a lot of the
questions that have come up in
linguistic philosophy
again have to be answered with
definiteness you know a typical question
in linguistic philosophy might be
something like um uh what what does it
mean
to refer to a thing when when what does
it
what is there what is what is the sort
of truth value of a statement
um and um how do you deal with the
possibility that the statement is about
something that doesn't exist
the the famous one that uh at least in
my mother's time was doing philosophy
um was uh the um uh the statement the
king of france is bald
well okay if you're making that
statement during the time of louis xv or
something
it could have a very definite yes it's
true no it's not true and so on
but if you're making that statement in
you know 1965
the france didn't have a king in 1965
what does that statement mean
is that statement a valid statement is
it a statement what does it what is the
truth value of that statement do all
statements have to have truth values
what happens when the thing that's in
the statement has nothing to refer to
well all of those questions are
questions we concretely have to answer
in welcome language what does it
actually do and
you know what does it do when you're
referring to a thing where there
isn't a a referent of that thing
and there's definite answers it treats
it as a symbolic thing
where it doesn't know what it is and it
has ways of dealing with that and so on
so so these things which sort of
were debating points in linguistic
philosophy for example
actually have to turn into the actual
operation
of a computational language
all right let's see
well there's a question here about tips
about writing essays
you know i i write a fair amount um
i write you know i have um my sort of
writings
blog like thing um right now actually
last few days i've been writing
very much because i've been trying to
write
about these things called combinators
that have their 100th anniversary on
monday
um and uh um
tips about writing these things well you
know a tip that i should give myself
is it's always nicer if you can say
things
in less words but it takes
longer to write less for me
if there's if i'm if there's something
i'm trying to describe if there's an
idea i'm trying to describe i can
describe it
kind of much as i would say it but maybe
there's a more minimal way to do it
which might take somebody less time to
read
um and uh you know you can you can kind
of go back and and sort of try and
squeeze it down to less words i don't
think i spend as much effort trying to
do that
as as i might you know i think one of
the things that that one notices
for me when i when i'm writing
i usually because i don't usually have
that much time to write
i usually don't revise what i write very
much at all i usually get to the point
where i think i know what i'm talking
about
and then then i write and whatever i've
written is pretty much what
what's going to be the thing that that
is the final form
i mean i suppose one thing to say about
writing in general is
uh you know the only way you're going to
be able to write something reasonable
is if you know what you're talking about
i think um
in uh i used to always have a rule at
our company
about technical writing writing things
like software documentation
i called it the zeroth rule of software
documentation
zeroth rule is if you don't know what
you're talking about
when you write the documentation then
your readers don't stand a chance
so in other words uh before you start to
write
it's good to have collected your
thoughts to the point where
you kind of know what you're talking
about where you could explain them to
somebody
and and for me i tend to write very much
like i talk i think at least um and it
tends to be
i find that a good way to sort of have a
rhythm for what i'm writing
i think that um in
let's see i mean over time one
develops uh well all kinds of ways
to i suppose one of the issues is
how do you say what you mean people
sometimes particularly in the past would
have these writing styles particularly
in sort of more formal writing where
they would have very elaborate
constructions and so on and so on and so
on
it's like well if you just ask the
person what do you mean by that
they would give you some one or two
sentence description
and that would be great but when they
write it it would turn into this
ten sentence very elaborate gnarly thing
that's very hard for somebody to
understand i think it's a phenomenon
actually modern web writing that people
have gotten somewhat more direct
and the really the trick is can you say
something directly how would you say it
if you were just saying it to someone
and sometimes there are uh places where
you might
say you might have some sort of analogy
you would use
and that analogy is useful to put in
your writing i usually put it in double
quotes and things when it's kind of
not not really the thing that describes
what one's talking about but it's kind
of an analogy which is useful for
understanding what one's talking about
um i think that um well let's see what
should i what else can i
say about writing essays you know i i do
lots of this writing so
i should have something to say about it
um i think uh
um you know i tend to find
for me that uh you know i kind of have
to write in these blocks
and it's like i write until i get to the
end of a section then i stop
if i kind of stop in the middle of a
section it's kind of bad news
um because when i come back and i reread
what i wrote
i'm always like well i would say it a
little bit differently today
than i would have done yesterday and
it's very hard for me to kind of graft
on
uh the the end for something that i had
started writing so it's good
at least for me to write in chunks um
another thing that i found is is surgery
on writing
is is very dangerous and rarely works
that is you you wrote something and it's
like oh my gosh i got to put this new
piece of information into the thing i
already
wrote but there's a definite flow to
what you already wrote
and as you start saying oh but i've got
to put this extra piece of information
in
well then this piece of what you wrote
doesn't make sense anymore
you're pulling that thread and then well
then that thing doesn't make sense
and pretty soon you pull these enough
threads and the whole
piece untangles completely um and that's
so you know surgery on writing is is in
my experience very difficult
which is why sort of getting everything
uh sort of
as as organized in your thoughts as
possible before you start to write
is a good idea now you know i think in
modern times kids are taught to
write i don't know what they are five
paragraph essays and so on that taught
to have you know
hooks at the beginning of essays and so
on i to me
if if uh uh you know it's it's good to
to um uh by the time you're you're
writing an essay
to a particular formal structure kind of
everything's over you're not going to
write a a strong kind of uh
uh flowing um uh
flowing esvay um it's um it's going to
be um
um uh you know something which has some
which has is kind of um uh seems very
kind of wooden and i find the same thing
i mean a few times
when i've written things and when you
revise it too many
times you end up with something that um
uh
is um uh where
sort of the life that the the pros had
when you wrote it fairly quickly is
completely removed and it's turned into
something which yes it's formally
correct
but no it uh it's not really uh
something that a human would care about
i mean i think the the worst case of of
essays written in
in human language is probably you know
kids who write essays which are then
going to be graded
where actually some of the grading is
going to be done by a machine and it's
like
what are we doing here you know you
write an essay
the essay is going to be read by a
natural language processing
machine which is going to be trying to
pull out various different features of
what's going on and
you know do the sentences parsed
correctly all the following
you know words that might appear
appearing it's it's a
you know to write an essay for a human
to write an essay
that is to be read by machine is i think
a kind of a doomed proposition but you
know i think another thing that's
important to say is
i've been talking about essays that are
purely in human language
in english or whatever else sort of the
big future and the thing that
i'm very keen on is computational essays
essays which are a mixture
are being written in natural language
english or whatever
and computational language i mean you
write an essay you try and explain what
you're talking about
there are different ways you can explain
it you can explain it in words you can
explain
it with a picture you can explain it in
a computational language
where you're describing in where you're
using computational language
to describe the ideas you have and kind
of the concept of our
whole orphan language thing has been to
provide that kind of precise
computational language
that is a good way to talk about things
that can be talked about computationally
that's a kind of a very clear way to
organize and present
computational ideas and it's kind of it
provides something a little different
than the sort of english narrative text
it's like
and then here's what we're actually
talking about and here it is in
computational language
and then you can take that piece of
computational language and just run it
and you do it inside the essay
and gosh here's this picture and now you
can see the picture and understand
something from it
and that that's i think and sometimes it
can be more than a picture
it could be some kind of interactive
dynamic manipulable thing
um uh you know produced by some pieces
of language code
um that's in one's essay so i think
that's um that's kind of the um
in a sense to me that's sort of the the
future
of kind of uh essays about many kinds of
things
is computational essays essays that mix
ordinary narrative text with
computational language
that gives sort of a precise
specification of what's going on
and ca you can use then the computer
to take that computational language and
generate
kind of content pictures whatever else
that immediately kind of makes
your essay something that people can
understand at a level
beyond just reading the words and so on
so
when it comes to writing computational
essays i i think the main
story there is to write your computer
code
as clearly as you write english language
there's an art
to both things being clear can your
computational language be nice and short
there are tricks that you can do that
you can't do in english you can iconize
something let's say you're making a plot
and you've got all kinds of details
about this line should be green
and that thing should be dotted and so
on that's not really important to the
main communication
of what that plot looks like so a more
from language in a notebook you can just
iconize that you get a little blue blob
that it just says oh there are a bunch
of these options about how the plots
generate but just a blue blob
if you ran that piece of computational
language uh from your computational
essay
that blue blob will be read by the
computer
as something has all those options in it
or you can click it and see all those
options
but in terms of the sort of
communication of the computational
language you don't have to see those
options
that's something you don't really get to
do with with natural language maybe you
can have a footnote or something like
that but it's not really as elegant
and this is a case where you get to
really communicate clearly
and and as i say there's kind of an art
to writing clear code
to writing code where where it sort of
uh
explains what what it's talking about as
well as just being able to actually
execute for the computer what it's
talking about
and typically i would say in a
computational essay to reduce
the visible pieces of computational
language to maybe one or two at most two
lines long
is a good idea whether by iconization or
whether by breaking up the parts of some
description that you're giving
i mean it's kind of like if you're
writing english um and you write a
sentence that goes on for a whole page
that philosopher emmanuel kant who i was
mentioning earlier had a habit of doing
that
by the time you have a sentence that
goes on for a page it's pretty difficult
for humans to understand that
same thing with a big lump of
computational language that goes on for
a long time
unless it's sort of broken up in a
structured way it's hard for humans to
understand that
so i think the um uh and
you know when you're dealing with
computational essays one of the things
that's great
is um okay one one tip about
computational essays
one thing that one might think about
is okay i'm going to have in this
computational i say i'm going to have
all these great visualizations i'm going
to
show her in pictures what i'm talking
about et cetera et cetera et cetera
but let me first write everything and
then i'll go
clean it up and i'll put all those nice
pictures in okay
big mistake because what happens is and
this happened to me many many years ago
and i kind of
made it a lifelong principle to not be
caught by this again
um which is you know you do that
and then at the end of your project
you're making all these nice pictures
then you say okay let me generate all
these pictures okay you generate them
you look at them you say oh now i
understand what's going on
i wish i generated these pictures before
well you should have done
you should generate them early in the
project so that you get to have
all the advantages that you hope your
final readers will have
when they get to see those wonderful
visualizations that you're making
now in practice things don't necessarily
work that way because in practice
you may be kind of waiting to finish
some elaborate way of
arranging labels in a perfect fashion to
label some plots and so on and that
might not get done until
you're later in the project but at least
it's a good thing to aim for
to sort of have as much up front as
possible in terms of
of the way that you'll present things
and i would say that in terms of
of uh you know in general
the idea that i'll do a project and then
i'll explain how to present it
i think is is a mistake i think that
knowing how to present something is an
integral part of doing
a clear piece of work and you know if
there's a thing where one is uh you know
it's it's not sort of an add-on at the
end
now sometimes after you've done the
piece of work and you've really
understood it
you get to find a simpler way to explain
it than you would have had earlier on
but i think even from sort of an early
phase of a project
it's worthwhile to think how would you
explain this maybe you'd even start
writing
some kind of description of it um it
depends on your kind of
workflow whether that actually makes
sense but but
early in the project so that you can
know that you know what you're talking
about
um i mean again one of the things that's
great about computational essays and in
the sense when i do
projects the uh uh what i'm generating
as i do the projects is endless
notebooks hundreds and hundreds perhaps
of notebooks
um each essentially computational essays
and those notebooks if i'm working
really quickly they'll probably have
very little english text in them
mostly computational language which i
can read perfectly well
um but uh those those notebooks
represent kind of the thought process
and i'm always going back to old
notebooks that i had
um that i wrote long ago in fact i was
just looking even yesterday
at notebooks that i wrote in 1992 which
i'm happy to say because we've managed
to keep compatibility in the world from
language
over all those years they they run just
fine the only thing that's really weird
about those notebooks
i bring them up on my great big computer
screen now and they're tiny
they're like i had no idea computer
screens or notebooks were ever that
narrow
they're like gosh how could you ever see
anything in that shorter space
but uh but but the computational
language in them still runs
okay oh lots of other questions here
um it's a question um
um okay the question from amarita here
why do the electron and proton have the
same amount of charge
it's a good question we don't yet know
definitively what the answer that is
one of the things that's observed in
physics is that
charge electric charge is quantized it
means it comes in
in uh definite multiples of a elementary
unit
the the electron has one unit actually
minus one unit
of elementary charge um well one unit of
charge one
it's equal to sort of the elementary
charge confusingly when quarks were
discovered in the 1960s
and uh sort of confirmed in the 1970s
quarks have one third of a unit of
charge and that was a very
that was something people got very
confused about but so far as we know
there's nothing with a smaller charge
than one third of the
of an elementary charge one third the
charge of the electron
now we know to very high accuracy that
the electron and proton have the same
electric charge if they didn't
then hydrogen atoms wouldn't be
electrical neutral a hydrogen atom that
has a proton in it an electron in it
those charges the proton has plus one
the electron has minus one
if they weren't exactly plus and minus
one then
there would be uh elec then then
hydrogen atoms would have a
a net charge and the universe would work
very differently than it does
but why are those two things that do
they have precisely the same charge we
don't know for sure
i have some ideas based on our theory of
physics
i have i have a guess that it's kind of
something like
the following if you imagine that you're
winding something around and you're
you're saying i'm gonna wind it around
uh you know you're you're winding a
string around a pole or something
and you say i'm going to wind it around
it's got to come back to where it
started from
well you don't get to wind it you know
three quarters of you know
the only way that you can have it come
back to where it started from is to wind
it a whole number of times
and so there's a much fancier version of
that homotopy
that shows up in mathematics and i have
a suspicion that the
reason that the charges of of particles
like electrons and protons
are exact integer multiples of each
other has to do with the fact that those
charges are associated with homotopy
associated with things like you can only
wind an interesting number of times and
come back to where you started from
but the actual details of how that works
is a lot more complicated than that
uh we have some very definite ideas
about how that might work
um in these models that we have based on
uh rewriting hypergraphs and so on
and this kind of structure in which one
can have kind of a
a way of kind of tangling up these
hypographs and they're only
a certain a certain discrete stat of
possible tanglings that
um are conceivable if you want the
tanglings a little bit like the winding
that's winding this thing around
a a you know string around a pole or
something is um
that in order for these tanglings to
sort of line up properly with themselves
they have to be an integer number of a
whole number of of uh
of pieces now actually in in physics
um in traditional physics there is one
uh weird way that people have thought
about explaining the quantization of
charge
it's a slightly technical thing it has
to do with things called magnetic
monopoles
so when you have an electric charge
great
as electric charge you can have a a
single electron that has an electric
charge
okay when you have a magnet a typical
bar magnet has a north pole and a south
pole
the magnetic field is this kind of line
this vector
that goes let's say from the south to
the north pole of the magnetic
of the magnet you say well why can't i
saw one end of the magnet off and just
have a north pole without having a south
pole
can i have a magnetic monopole well if
you saw the magnet in half
you'll still have a north pole on a
south pole the place where you sword the
magnet will be another south pole so to
speak
the magnet is only only able to have
be set up with this both north pole and
south pole a dipole
so people have wondered whether there
might be magnetic monopoles
in the standard theory of physics there
aren't magnetic monopoles
but if there was a magnetic monopole
even just one magnetic monopole in the
whole universe
it would force charge to be quantized
and actually the way it forces charge to
be quantized is very much like this
homotopy argument
i was describing um that that uh
in order for that to be consistency in
the way that electromagnetism works
it's necessary for electric charge to be
quantized if magnetic monopoles exist
now obviously people have looked for
magnetic monopoles
nobody's ever found one uh probably they
don't exist in our universe
but if they did as a matter of
consistency charge would have to be
quantized but other than that
explanation
we don't know a reason why charge is
quantized unless we're dealing with
something like our theory of physics
where we can start to see sort of
underneath what's happening in space and
time and what's happening in quantum
mechanics
and we can start to have sort of real
explanations for things like the
quantization of charge
and hopefully in the next few months we
will know a lot more about um
about that kind of the buzz phrases have
to do with local gauging variants
and gauge groups and the limiting
of uh this sort of complicated
hypographs not just
limiting to something like ordinary
space physical space
but also limiting to this internal
symmetry space
um that's governed by uh so so so just
like
you can ask about in in space whether
you can kind of continuously move from
one point to another
or whether space is more like a fluid
like water where there are sort of
discrete molecules there whether they're
sort of discrete atoms of space that's
one question you can ask
another question you can ask is if
you're rotating things around
are there a discrete set of rotations or
a continuous set of rotations
you can ask that about ordinary space
you can also ask that about sort of
internal features
of of in particle physics for example
where there are these kind of
internal uh constructs
that behave a bit like um sort of
rotation in space but they're not
rotation
ordinary space their rotation in for
example color space
in in qcd and the theory of quarks and
gluons there's this notion of color
space you can talk about rotations
in color space and there's a question of
are those continuous rotations or are
they in discrete jumps
and the belief is that just as when you
have a large number of sort of atoms of
space
things behave as if you have sort of a
continuous space so
similarly when you have these very
complicated hypergraphs
that it will be the case that these sort
of internal rotations
in for example color space will also
behave continuously in mathematical
terms
that there'll be a limit in the case of
ordinary space there's a limit to
sort of a manifold that represents space
in the other case it's a limit
to a manifold that represents a lead
group which is the the kind of a
description of a continuous group
associated with things like color
rotations and that's kind of the the
thing we think is is going to happen
there
um there's a question here from joel
asking why can't magnetic monopoles
exist
um well we don't know if magnetic
monopoles exist
but in the standard equations of
electromagnetism
there's an equation these were equations
written down by james
maxwell in the 1870s 1880s
um and they are the standard equations
of electromagnetism there's one
important equation it says
div b equals zero um and b
stands for the magnetic field and div is
the divergence of the magnetic field
and what that means is the magnetic
field you can think of
magnetic field as being a bunch of field
lines they say
kind of if you had a um uh if you had a
bunch of iron filings they would sort of
follow these these field lines if you
have something which is following
the magnetic field from the south pole
to the north pole or something you're
following the field lines
okay so maxwell's equation div equals
zero says there is never a divergence of
magnetic field lines there's never a
place
where it kind of looks like an idealized
hedgehog where all the lines
come out of a point there's another
equation that says div
e equals the electric charge
e is the electric field it is the case
that electric field can
have this sort of hedgehog form where
the electric field lines
uh diverge from a point that has an
electric charge at it
what you would have to have if you had a
magnetic monopole is that similar
divergence to magnetic field lines
the equations say it isn't there but of
course the equations are made up to
describe how the physical world works
and so i'm not really telling you why
there aren't magnetic monopoles i'm just
saying that with
the standard equations of
electromagnetism which seem to work
really well
there aren't magnetic monopoles but
beyond that we don't know
a good reason why magnetic monopoles
shouldn't exist
they just aren't part of the standard
theory and once you have that theory
when you build it up into things like
quantum electrodynamics the quantum
theory of photons and electrons
and electromagnetism uh that whole
structure of quantum electrodynamics
is built on the assumption that magnetic
monopoles do not exist
so if magnetic monopoles suddenly do
exist you have to kind of redo the whole
structure of quantum electrodynamics
let's see um
well there's a question here
um well there's a question from flymo
as well as thinking about the sape warf
hypothesis do you think about how humans
might be thinking in the future
paradigms of thought in the future yeah
so one of the
questions it's a it's a big one for
somebody like me actually is to what
extent
does the language that we are um
um uh
the the the language we use affect the
way we think about things
and this has been a long argument
there's this thing called the sapi war
hypothesis from the 1940s
1950s uh which was kind of the
hypothesis that
the way one talks about things affects
the way one thinks about things
sometimes what one thinks about affects
how one talks about or what one talks
about um
if if uh you know if if you don't
um if you live in a different
environment you're going to be talking
about different kinds of things
you know if you if you live in a place
where there's lots of snow you'll
probably have elaborate words for
different kinds of snow
if you live in a place where there's
never any snow you might have one word
for snow but you're not going to go into
the micro details of
of snow if you um uh and
and sometimes so so there's there's
things like that but then there are
questions like
okay let's say words for colors what
words do we have for colors we have a
code word for blue we have a word for
green
we might have a word for teal we might
have a few other words
what words do we have and how do the
words that we have for colors
um how do they affect the way that we
think about things like colors and
for example it's a sort of famous claim
that uh in things like ancient greek
um there wasn't really a a a word for i
think blue
um and so things that we would now talk
say were blue were described as sort of
greenish or whatever else in that
language
how does that affect the way we think
about things we don't fully know the
answer to that for human language
for computational languages i think we
much more know the answer i i've
certainly seen it
much more in practice that for example
with our from language
you know i've take it as a major
responsibility in my life
to design that language in such a way as
to let people think about things in a
clear way when it comes to thinking
about
about things computationally and i can
really tell that when there's a concept
that we put into the language as kind of
a word in the language
that's a sort of anchor for thinking
about things in a certain kind of way
and i know for myself i think oh that's
a fold list kind of operation
if i didn't have a word for it i
wouldn't think of it that way
i would think of it in terms of some
underlying constituents but i wouldn't
sort of collect it together and think
about it in that same way and i think
words provide an important way to sort
of organize our thoughts
to decide kind of what we think about
it's the same thing as when um
uh you know there'll be a name for some
field of science
and the very fact that there's a name
for it uh allows a lot of things to be
built on top you know then there can be
an institute for
science x and there can be this so there
can be that and people people can talk
about it
names for things are important now the
question of
of how that will evolve going into the
future interesting question
there are things that um i mean this
this sort of
trend towards more levels of uh
you know different when something
becomes popular then
there starts to be a word for it and
once there's a word for it people can
talk in terms of it and they can kind of
build ideas on top
of that and that's a process that's been
going on throughout the evolution of
language
and that's a process we can expect to go
on uh in the future
the interaction of that with
computational language is kind of
interesting
because computational language is a
designed language
and so it allows one to have sort of a a
better forcing function
to kind of make progress in in defining
things one can think about
now you know there's a question are
there things that we just don't
understand today
because we don't have the right
sort of way of thinking about them the
right language for describing them
absolutely yes i mean i can see in the
progress of science and technology that
i've done
when when one didn't have sort of the
right framework for thinking about and
talking about things
even when the sort of the facts of the
situation were right in front of one's
nose
one didn't understand them until one had
the sort of framework for thinking about
things
and over time we get new frameworks for
thinking about things
and we can expect that more things will
be able to be understood
i mean i've been working just recently
on these on these weird things called
combinators
i can explain one thing about
combinators that relates to language
and it's very weird thing so in ordinary
language
we have uh we have nouns we have things
like you know
um you know the the dog was chasing the
cat or something
dog cat nouns but then we also have
pronouns
we say like um i don't know
um
jim said hello to jane and
she was happy okay well
the she is a pronoun that refers to the
noun
jane and actually because of you know
the way gender
works in english um the you know we kind
of with that sentence
you know john said hello to jane knows
i'm saying
um we can we have these two different
pronouns and at least in the the you
know the current version of english
um the we can we can distinguish those
two different possible subjects that are
pronouns
by the gender of those pronouns in other
languages it works differently
um sometimes there aren't genders or
pronouns sometimes there are
more pronouns and so on um but the
the main point is that that we can use
pronouns to refer to things
without having specific nouns that say
what those things are
but there's a question of uh okay
do we really uh do we do
when do we need to name the things we're
talking about
so for example if i say uh
jim was talking to bill who was talking
to this person who's talking to that
person
i couldn't really say he to refer to
something there because the he
can only refer to one thing and there's
lots of different he's in that sentence
and so how do we disambiguate that well
in
computational language or in in
mathematics
we would say you know call bill x
and jim y and then we can refer to x and
y and we're all good
um the question is do we really need
that do we really need those
those variables or not or can we have
sort of an elaborate system of pronouns
that sort of says well this refers to
that because then the structure this is
in that place and that place and so on
well the answer is that a hundred years
ago a chap called moses sean finkel
figured out
how you can do that in complete
generality how you can avoid
ever having to name things how you can
always just describe
things and he did it in the context of
mathematical logic
how you can kind of describe things just
by how things relate to things
without ever having to give a name to
anything
so what he did is is very interesting
it's it's very
it was very important for theoretical
purposes a lot of things were built on
top of it knowing that it was in
principle possible
was very important but if you actually
try and use it
it's absolutely incomprehensible to
humans at least
well at least to me and i think to to to
pretty much everybody else i mean it's
it's kind of sort of a famous
thing that combinators and commentary
logic are something well you can in
principle do things with combinators
but you'd never want to because they're
just utterly obscure
they're really very non-human in the way
that they work
you have these big complicated
expressions of s's and k's
and they represent oh this thing goes
there and that thing goes there and they
they untangle in this way and they run a
bunch of steps and you can see them
untangling and it's really cool
but absolutely incomprehensible so
that's an
interesting example of something where
it's kind of a
you know a um uh the the the idea of
these combinators is sort of a world
without nouns that you never have to
name anything
and um uh you know can we humans deal
with such a world
i don't know over the last hundred years
we've
uh complete failure um you know people
haven't dealt with that
people don't understand that um is it
the case
could it be the case if we really cared
that we would sort of gradually build
out a sort of conceptual framework
where people say oh yeah it's obvious
how that works kind of an analogous
thing is the following that that
you know when we have oh i don't know
sentence structure
our sentences tend to be linear
sequences this
is a sentence about meaning or something
it's a it's a linear sequence of words
and we can kind of
break it down into a tree where we're
saying you know noun
verb noun things like that and that's
sort of a tree where they
where we can say that's uh the the maybe
the noun is broken into an
adjective and a noun and the verb has an
adverb and this and that and so on and
it's kind of this tree of
of different structures um that make up
our sentence and and
our brains are pretty good at taking
that sequence of things in
and sort of uh you know understanding
parsing them into that tree
and and seeing what it means you know we
lose it
if for example the the the tree goes too
deep
so we say uh you know
the cat would chase the mouse which
chased the fish which chased the
whatever which tasted whatever whatever
whatever
after we've gone to sufficiently many
levels deep usually more than about five
it's really hard for a human to
understand what was going on
um and you know when you pop back up to
the top again
and then you say and it was happy or
something
it's like what did you say hard to
understand
so we have some practical limitations
like that but the question is
is this structure uh of you know
sentences
broken down hierarchically like this
which is by the way also the way that
computational language breaks
down its way of presenting things same
kind of hierarchical setup
is is that an intrinsic thing that we
kind of have to have for the way our
brains work
an example of how that wouldn't be the
way things work
is if you've got this whole network of
this connects to this and that connects
to that
and it's not a story of this thing
followed by this thing followed by this
thing followed by that thing
that thing inside that thing inside that
thing like in a hierarchy
it's more just everything's connected
things are connected in its whole
network of
of of of items and that's by the way
more how combinators work
um for these purposes and the fact is
it's pretty hard for people to
understand that
it's kind of like you have an uh you
have something and it's a bunch of wires
connecting things together
it's the wires aren't organized it's
just this big nest wires
it's like what's going on here it's hard
for people to understand that
you know i've done a bunch of
experiments on computational languages
trying to see whether one can make use
of the essentially visual input of
having this sort of
collection of wires this sort of this
connects to this and this and this and
this and this
rather than some kind of linear sequence
and so far
over the last 40 years or so i've been
trying to do these things so far all of
those have been kind of failures
i actually have a new idea so it's
possible that there's there's a new
direction there
but um you know there's really a
question of can can we humans
sort of build our cognitive apparatus
in the direction where we understand
things like that or is there something
that really pretty much cuts us off from
that are there stepping stones we can go
to get there um that you know in another
you know some number of years it'll be
like everybody understands that i mean
an example of something that might be
thought to be difficult to understand
is uh the way hyperlinks work
the way you're linking it's like a graph
you go from here to here to here to here
to here
if you explain that abstractly without
the concrete
instance of hyperlinks it might be hard
to understand but people don't get that
confused
by hyperlinks and this idea that that
you know you can link from one page to
another and so on and so on and so on
um so you know i think that particularly
as some of these concepts get embedded
in things that
are sort of everyday i think it becomes
easier to understand them
i mean for example one thing in thinking
about physics quantum mechanics has
always been an area
that's hard to understand as from our
theory of physics
we're realizing that the underlying
formalism of quantum mechanics
is deeply related to the underlying
formalism of many other kinds of things
like
distributed computing like the way that
you can have
large networks of computers doing things
and so on it's also
potentially related to a way that one
can think about kind of
ways to build sort of financial systems
with blockchains and things like this
well if it turns out we can use the
formalism that comes from our physics
project
that is deeply related to quantum
mechanics to make this kind of
distributed blockchain for doing
financial transactions well it'll be a
fun thing in itself
but also it will mean that when people
use that routinely
they will end up having an intuitive
sense of the way things work in quantum
mechanics
of things like oh you can't make these
two measurements simultaneously and
there's this uncertainty and the et
cetera et cetera et cetera those will be
things where people instead of those
being
weird physics effects that have to be
explained to one there'll be things that
people say oh yeah i understand that
because
i'm used to that because that's the way
my financial transactions work and so on
uh
let's see okay i'm going to have to wrap
up soon because i need to get back to my
my uh own writing effort here
um
let's see
uh you know people ask these questions
about do i have an opinion about
such and such a paper and so on those
are those are
super difficult questions to answer you
know i i i do a certain amount of work
on
history of science and that requires me
really digging deeply
into particular historical papers
it takes a lot of work to really know
what
you know what people said and what they
were thinking and so on
and um it's usually when there's a when
there's a
sort of a live human who wrote something
my general approach is just ask the
person
um and uh um
it doesn't uh uh you know it's it's it's
it's hard to um it's hard to be sure
that one is correctly representing
um what they're talking about
um
ah let's see
super skeptical asks the simple question
of me how are you
you know that varies from day to day but
right now i'm i'm in major crunch mode
trying to finish some things that i'm
hoping to do uh for the centenary of
combinators
but it's a lot of fun it's very
interesting both the technical side of
it and the historical side of it are
very interesting and i
and i love doing things that uh like
that
and um i would say that the um uh you
know a funny thing
that's happened in in my life i guess is
i've been working on a bunch of
different
uh sort of major directions for a great
many years whether it's about
computational language whether it's
about
understanding the fundamental theory of
physics whether it's about understanding
the sort of implications of computation
the sort of computational universe of
programs
all these kinds of things there are all
these different sort of threads that
i've been working on for a long time
and building building a lot of kind of
tools and
and understanding in these different
areas one of the things that's happened
in recent times
uh is that a lot of things that are
really sort of coming to fruition things
that i've instead of building for a long
time it's like
yes now we've got a finished version now
we've got something that works from this
i mean a big place where that's happened
is in this fundamental theory of physics
where i'd sort of built a lot of tools
and ideas and and then suddenly in the
last year they've all come together
and actually that particular phenomenon
of those things all coming together
after so many years
of sort of having them be vaguely being
thought about and making slow progress
and so
on it's very encouraging to me to say
okay let me take the other five projects
that i really want to do
and let's see if i can actually do them
and um there are several
that actually are really up on the um
are hitting the front burner i suppose
in in um uh one of them is this idea of
symbolic discourse language
the notion of being able to express uh
not just the kinds of things we've
expressed so far in computational
language
but a lot more kind of everyday uh kind
of things that we would express a
natural language
being able to express that in a symbolic
computational form
that's something i've been thinking
about for a long time i think finally
i'm going to make a serious assault on
that
it's a project that got started not by
me obviously
in the 1600s by people like leibniz and
and uh wilkins and other kinds of people
are building philosophical languages but
people kind of gave up
since then they just thought it was too
difficult or whatever we're now in a
position
and i think i'm probably now in a
position from having spent the last
you know 40 years thinking about
computational language design i'm now in
a position to actually do this
and so that's a that's a project that i
want to do
and there are other projects like one
that um i've been sort of thinking about
for a really long time
is how to make molecular scale computers
how to compute
and build things sort of to order on a
molecular scale
and um that's something uh you know in a
sense biology
we are the only successful example so
far
of molecular scale computing you know
what we do is
uh the way we work so to speak is to
have all these molecules inside us
that uh sort of operate
to get things done to to make sort of to
make life happen so to speak
um and um in our
uh when we build computers we're
building them at a scale
very very very much bigger than than
individual molecules
um and the question is can we make
something which is sort of a
computational system
that works at a molecular scale maybe a
system that can actually just construct
molecules
uh sort of construct to order a molecule
that's this weird shape or that weird
shape
rather than having to go through the
sort of standard mechanisms of chemistry
um to get there and i recently realized
that a bunch of things i've done
uh to do with our physics project to do
with even this project about combinators
yes there is a way forward i think i
know how to do this
and not only that there's a company
we've been working with for a long time
that's built a lot of technology using
our technology stack
to make a big automated lab um that uh
and i think that we might actually be
able to really do this
and actually do in a sense uh molecular
scale computing
um and have sort of a a way of compiling
down to molecules
uh in a sense that would be an exciting
thing because like biology is our only
example
this is kind of biology 2.0 of a of a
different way to do molecular scale
computing
um and you know i think that uh perhaps
all the things have lined up
so that it's actually now the time to do
that and and
the existence of this automated lab
which is programmable with wolfram
language
um is uh for me is an important piece of
that because
uh uh otherwise it's like me with test
tubes and
you know actually doing a physical uh
physical experiments with molecules and
so on
is is it's not something i i know much
about
um and uh it's not something that would
take
it would probably take me years to kind
of develop sort of the
the skills necessary to do that
effectively but uh
but it looks like we're just going to be
able to do that um by you know typing
often language
scripts rather than having to actually
move the test tubes around yourself
get the robots to do it for you so to
speak so and there are
well i have a a series of these projects
about probably about five of them
which i'm now very enthused about um
about really being able to do
um i have to say that that um uh you
know another direction that i find
interesting is uh uh kind of explaining
things and
uh uh exposition of things you know
that's why i'm doing these um
uh these live streams and so on um and
i'm trying to figure out what the best
way
to take my interest in that and the
things that i know
and uh sort of find the best delivery
mechanism
um for that uh to the world that that
is both both uh both i find fulfilling
and is useful
um and so that's that's another
challenge but um but yeah the the
the basic answer to uh uh to
how am i i'm doing very well these days
um although my uh uh things are very
very busy because there's just it's such
a strange thing that there are these
projects that i've been working on for
decades
that are all sort of coming to fruition
um
even a lot of stuff to do with the
actual deployment of orphan language in
the world at large
lots of things happening there very
practical kinds of things
but things where things were like yes
i've intended this to happen for 20
years
now it's actually happening okay there's
things for me to actually do on the uh
associated with those things happening
and so that that tends to generate just
a lot of stuff to do but but it's really
interesting and i suppose that for me
the challenge is
do i get to do things that i think are
worth me doing or am i doing things
where somehow
it's like uh this is a why am i doing
this
well i a very large fraction of the time
i'm getting to do things where i say
this is a
good use of my time this is something
that is both
fulfilling to me and uh build something
interesting
and uh and it's kind of something where
people in the world at large get benefit
from it
so that's that's pretty nice um
all right i should really wrap um very
soon here there's
there's a question here um
would you advise today's generation z
folk to become independent researchers
rather than academics
boy you know academia is a good
framework for doing all kinds of things
you know if you want to research some
weird thing you don't know what it's
good for but it's interesting
there's a decent chance you'll get to do
that in academia it's not perfect
chance because academia has its own
structure where it's like oh you've got
to get funding for that
oh does it fit into physics or does it
fit into
computer science or chemistry or things
that get funding and so on
um so it's not a perfect version of that
but there's
a lot that you can do in sort of
research in academia where you don't
immediately have to say and now i know
how it's going to turn into a product
for example
i think that um for me the um
uh the dynamics of uh of companies and
things like that
work uh you know in the way that i at
least i built a company
work very well but that's because i've
kind of managed to find a
niche where the things that i find
intellectually interesting
are really very well aligned with the
things that we can actually deliver as
products
when i have some idea about
computational language it can get put in
well from language
and it can turn into a product that
people get and that run on
runs on all kinds of computers and in
all kinds of organizations around the
world
and it's something that's immediately
useful to people i have kind of a a
matrix through which to put
ideas that i have when you're in
academia the main matrix
through which you put ideas is writing
academic papers
and if your ideas sort of if you can get
it to an academic paper but you can't
quite figure out
how to get it into something that's kind
of useful to the world and the product
and things like that
then that's kind of the the right option
but you know it's a different thing it's
like
you can do a project and it'll be good
for a paper
and terrible for a product you can do a
project that's great for a product
and not very good for a paper you know
in a paper
it's like well we did this and we did
this one example and it worked great and
here's the result
and it's like you look at that from the
point of view of a product you say
that's useless nobody's actually going
to try that one example people want to
do all these different examples and all
these different cases
and that one example it's kind of cool
it's kind of interesting to read about
but it's not useful as a product
similarly when you're building a product
there are things where you say well
people are going to give us
all these different kinds of input if
it's a software product and we've got to
be able to deal with all of them you've
got to have all these heuristics for
dealing with these different cases and
all these different things and it's
really kind of complicated and it's
intellectually perhaps quite interesting
but you say let's write a paper about
this how are we going to write a paper
we could say
here's the code great it's computational
i say that be fine
but if we're going to say and this has
10 heuristics that are associated with
if it's this case that case the other
case
it's like that's not the kind of thing
that would be interesting in an academic
paper
that's the kind of thing that's very
useful in a product not interesting in
academic paper
it's it's it's a it's an intellectually
interesting thing
uh just as that one example for the
academic paper is an intellectually
interesting thing but there's sort of
different tracks
and i think that's the thing to
recognize in in um
uh in in the way that those those things
work
now you know one of the challenges is
you know being an independent researcher
well you know in the practicality of the
world
people have to make a living somehow and
uh
it's it's great if you can make a living
doing the thing that you really want to
do
you know i think i'm pretty really very
lucky that i managed to at least
construct for myself
a mechanism where i pretty much get to
make a living from doing the things i
like to do
um but uh you know that's that's
there's a lot of work to building such a
structure for oneself
and a lot of things that require skills
that when
not everybody necessarily has and so
it's a you know that's
not necessarily for everything for
everybody kind of thing
but so you know one model of life is
you kind of you make a living doing
something
and then you have a thing you're really
interested in doing that's different
from the thing you make a living doing
maybe you're interested in the thing you
make a living doing but you're also
interested in something else
that isn't something you make could make
a living doing i mean like for example
i find doing these live streams
interesting i
just has nothing to do with the way i
make a living i just do this for fun
um and uh it's you know it's it's it's a
it's a hobby so to speak
um and that's a fine way to to exist um
i think when it comes to doing
scientific research there is also the
possibility
of just do it as a hobby unfortunately
many fewer people than one might think
succeed in doing that
there are definitely people who do and
many who i know
who do it quite successfully but it's a
it's actually it's it's it's it's in
these years it's surprisingly unusual
100 years ago it was much more common
these days it's less common now perhaps
one of the reasons for that
is that in a sense it's easier to do
meaningful
research when there's a matrix in which
you're doing it
when you're writing academic papers when
you're building products
it's somehow easier to make concrete the
research you're doing
when you have an environment like that
and you know when you're an independent
researcher it's like well i don't really
care about writing papers
i don't really care about making
products okay how do you
make something out of your research now
actually
you know we've tried to provide some
venues in the wolfram community
in our function repository things like
that for people doing computational
kinds of things
it's a venue for it doesn't matter who
you are where you are what
what environment you're embedded in so
to speak this is a place where you can
do an interesting piece of work
and get it out there in the world and
have it be a finished thing
because you know one of the things
that's sort of deadly sometimes in
in in research kinds of things is the
the never finished project
you know it's like well i'm working on
this i'm working on this i'm working on
this
there's no end point there's nothing
there's no you know yes i've got to this
definite milestone in the project
and i think it's really useful to have
that and people can spend uh you know
unfortunately
people do spend you know a lot of time
doing sort of hobby projects where there
aren't really those milestones those
endpoints those actual
pieces of stuff that get produced and
sometimes
it can be very that isn't a very healthy
way to do it and one of the problems
that happens is
when you have to for example explain
what you're doing then you have to start
from the beginning
if you're going to do a good job
explaining it at least you have to start
from the beginning explain the steps
get to where you're getting to you kind
of can't get away with not
starting from the beginning but if
you're just thinking about something
you never have to explain you're just
like well this is my hobby and i'm just
doing it and i
don't really have to explain it to
anybody and so on you don't necessarily
have to go back and think about it from
the beginning
and maybe you realize after you've been
doing it for a decade
then somebody says well can you explain
it and you go back to the beginning you
say
oh my gosh that wasn't really right
the thing i started from wasn't really
right well you would have discovered
that
a lot earlier if you'd kind of had this
milestone that you
that you're trying to hit of saying i'm
going to explain it now
so i think that's an important um kind
of that that's one thing that's sort of
a danger of the kind of
the pure independent researcher kind of
thing now you know there are different
environments
you know between sort of academia uh you
know there's sort of academia where the
product is papers basically
um there's uh companies like mine where
the product is products
um and there are some small set of kind
of interme
intermediate kind of research institutes
where it's sort of something in between
usually the product is some kind of
report
usually there's something concrete
that's produced i i remember
oh you know when people have tried to
set up sort of pure thinking
institutes doesn't typically work very
well
i mean it's um i i don't think we we
humans are built for that i think if you
say to somebody
you know okay you're some age you know
just think for the rest of your life
it doesn't matter what you produce just
think that's that's the very difficult
thing to do
i certainly wouldn't be able to do that
i mean my you know i do a lot of
thinking i enjoy thinking very much and
spend a large fraction of my time doing
it but
for me sort of thinking the way the
thinking becomes real
is by actually producing things by
writing things down by writing
pieces of computational language by by
explaining things to people and so on
and so on and so on
i think this idea of just sit and think
is
is one that humans find really difficult
it's kind of like a
like being it's it's it's a very
isolating kind of
kind of idea and i've seen
institutionally when people try and sort
of set up
let's get a bunch of clever people and
just have them think it usually doesn't
work very well
it's usually much better when there's
this sort of concrete output
that the people trying to get and
sometimes people say oh that concrete
output is really mundane and boring and
you know people should just be thinking
these higher thoughts
turns out people think much in my
experience people think much better
higher thoughts
when there's a concrete output than when
they're just sort of floating around
and even when that concrete output seems
quite mundane and this is certainly
something i've seen a lot
you know even when it's like we're going
to solve this practical problem
it has to do with the sort of
computational issue this that and the
other
and then when you really dig into it you
realize actually
the reason people haven't solved this
problem before is because there's this
great big
intellectual chasm there that has to be
crossed
and that's really interesting and
although it came out of this kind of
mundane question
the reason people didn't get the mundane
question answered is because they had to
figure out all this deeper intellectual
stuff and you're kind of driven to that
by thinking about this mundane question
you never would have touched it you
never would have noticed it was there
had you not had this entry through this
seemingly quite mundane question let's
see
all right maybe one um
uh
i think i should go because i really
need to
go work on my um efforts in uh
combinators there's one last question
here which i don't quite know the um
uh the meaning of which is from memes of
destruction it's
do you like turtles
uh that that has me a bit
flawed when i was a kid i i
i used to keep a certain collection of
pets
usually for some reason reptiles and
amphibians
um i don't know quite why but i had what
in british english
it's called a telepin but i think in
american it's called a turtle
there's a small little very very
brightly uh
pigmented little critter um
i thought it was kind of cool i'm not
sure i would say anything profound about
it
um when um uh i'll say two other two
other things about turtles
um by a way of sort of free association
there's a um there's a kind of a funny
saying when people
are talking about fundamental theories
of physics
um turtles are a are a thing that
commonly come up there and i think the
reason is i think it's burton russell a
uh well-known philosopher not not one of
my great favorites but
um uh the um who um
lived a long life in england um uh
must have uh died in the 1970s i think
um the um uh he um
uh he was apparently i think it was him
was was uh apparently giving a talk
somewhere
and a woman asks him says
he's talking about something about
physics and fundamental theory of
physics
um i hope i have the right person i hope
it was burton russell not
not arthur eddington that tells the
story but i think it was burton russell
um the um uh the woman
apparently says to him look i don't know
what your theory of physics is all about
but what's really going on in the
universe is the world is
is uh exists on the top of a giant
turtle
and um that's that's the way the world
is constructed there's a there's a giant
turtle there
and the earth is somehow uh on the on
the back of the giant turtle and thing
things like that um the um
uh and it's like and then
the person giving the talk bertrand
russell whoever it was uh
says to this woman well well what's that
turtle standing on top of
and she said well it's another turtle
and it says well what's that one
standing on top of
and apparently this this this woman said
look
you just don't understand it's turtles
all the way down
and so that phrase you know turtles all
the way down has become a little bit of
a joke phrase
to describe you know theories of physics
and
uh you know it's hypographs all the way
down or whatever else
um so that's kind of a a you know a
turtle an abuse of turtles
um the um um
the okay so then uh i see somebody sent
a thing about
uh zombie kid likes turtles and youtube
okay this is you see this is the problem
i'm i'm i'm obviously
um uh um
i'm obviously out of my depth in in
modern popular culture and i i should
learn all these memes
it's kind of a shame i i would have
thought i was exposed enough
through my own children and through
interacting with kids i i do try and
learn the means but i'm obviously not
doing as good a job
as i should be at that um any case i'll
i'll mention one more turtle
piece of turtleism so
there's a um a very early computer
language
that was intended for kids named logo
it's kind of modern version of it is
is this thing called scratch and
the idea of logo it originated in 1960s
with a guy called simon pappert
at mit um was the idea was
it was a language where it would all be
about controlling a turtle
on the screen and you'd say go forwards
go turn left turn right
keep going et cetera et cetera et cetera
and make all these kind of patterns and
so on
and and this was the um and so the
question and for example the logo
language actually
got uh is it very interesting uh some
countries like um
i think the country of costa rica for
example sort of taught it to all the
kids
at one point and i think that's how it's
kind of interesting to trace
the effect of kind of teaching a a a
computer language an early computer
language
um you know back in the 70s and 80s and
so on
um to to a wide range of kids what
effect has it had
and those kinds of things i'm afraid
it's not quite as dramatic as effect
as one might hope i think because sort
of the
the distance between sort of controlling
a turtle on the screen
and doing serious kind of computational
language kinds of things is
is fairly great i mean i would argue
that it's the job of a language designer
like me to make our computational
language
accessible to kids so that kids can kind
of start
using uh sort of the same computational
language
that the grown-ups so to speak can use
um
early on rather than having to kind of
dumb down a sort of language for kids
but in any case
this language logo was was very
innovative and and uh
in its time and one question would be
why did seymour pappet think about uh
having a turtle running around on the
screen
well the answer is there was a thing
that was at the 1950
i might get this wrong 1955-ish
world's fair and it was um
a man called gray walter uh this first
name i can't remember grey walter was
his last name
um was doing kind of very early
artificial intelligence
and his sort of demo object
for the world's fair was a thing that
kind of ran around on the floor
and would have sensors which said oh it
ran into a wall turn around go backwards
kind of like a modern you know robotic
vacuum cleaner or something
um but it would it would kind of run
around on the floor and do these things
that had
various kinds of touch sensors i think
it may have had some kind of light
sensor as well
um and uh in order to to sort of make
this some
you know the form factor that this thing
operated within was this bunch of
electronics on wheels
and so gray walter ended up putting this
kind of dome on top of it
and and that dome um became um
uh sort of looked like a turtle so the
thing was was called the you know the
gray walter turtle
and actually it was pretty famous it was
uh it had its appearance you know it was
on the cover of time magazine and it was
uh
you know this is the future artificial
intelligence is almost here it's 1955.
um and uh um it's um it's kind of like
it's going to be robots all the way down
so to speak um
and uh it's kind of an interesting case
of of how did it come to be that um
even though the gray walter turtle which
had you know perhaps uh
i don't think it probably had
transistors in it not it certainly
didn't have vacuum tubes wouldn't have
been able to power vacuum tubes
um but um uh it
uh you know it was it was doing very
simple things the path
from that to sort of the true robot
is a long path um it's uh
um uh it's it's some uh
it's been a surprisingly long path but
any case the
the turtles uh not all the way down
for physics but turtles as they've
appeared in sort of uh the logo computer
language
and uh and now i think scratch has a
well scratch has this cat
called scratch i think which is the
modernized version of the turtle
um and uh the um so so that's kind of
the
the the the story behind that um i think
that the um
um i'm not sure you know the the
challenge
when logo was new kids had never seen
computers and the idea of a kid actually
being able to do something on a computer
was really a new idea at this point with
computer games the way they are
seeing this turtle move around on the
screen is hardly is hardly dramatic and
exciting
um it's uh it's just something that's
changed over time
all right i still don't know what zombie
kid likes turtles um
is about i need a summary of that um
uh or i'll have to actually go watch
this youtube video
um but um
uh oh should i watch it
all right well i'll see what i can do
back here live at the waterfront village
with my friend the zom
jonathan just got an awesome face paint
job what do you all right you're great
good time to hear it i don't know what
this is about
this seems seems um uh
hard for me to parse so i i i i lose
that meme i don't know what that meme is
about
um well that's nothing new right there
plenty of
it's it's always one of these things
where um
i'm more struck by the fact that uh
you know people are asking about how
language affects the way one thinks
about things
i think some of these memes are good
examples of how one can end up
in a situation where it's like i don't
know what you're talking about
um you know that thing is sick
okay you know i thought i knew the
meaning of the word sick but i know now
it has a new meaning
and that you know but i have to be able
to translate that
in what context can i translate in what
way you know in a sense language
the big thing about language is it
allows sort of people to communicate
with other people
but by the time you know when when you
develop these memes which one group
people knows about another group people
doesn't don't know about
that that sort of is is the perhaps it's
the beginning of a new piece of language
but it's also
a way that people don't understand what
other people are talking about same
thing
happens in fields of science where
somebody will have jargon in one area
and sometimes the jargon in one area
will collide with the drug in another
area
and you'll be talking about some the uh
well for example our we have this thing
in our physics theory called branchial
space
branchial space in american perhaps um
branch like branches of a tree branchial
space
well it turns out that uh one of the
good things about the word bronze shield
is that it doesn't get tagged by spell
correctors even though they haven't
heard about our theory of physics
because the word bronze shield also
shows up as a type of bone in a fish
so this is a typical example of you know
one person is talking about branch
shield space
in the physics budget and other people's
talk person's talking about it in fish
anatomy
and you don't know what you end up
talking about um
and i think that the uh um it's
um uh uh somehow these
these um the thing that really gets to
me i suppose is
is these word fashions that last such a
short time and
you can kind of see that if you look in
in like involvement language we have
some of these word frequency data
things and you'll see these particular
words like the word groovy
from the 1960s um you know had this very
short-lived period when it was
uh a cool groovy whatever word um
and uh you know i think that's a it's a
um
well the question for an old foggy like
me is is uh how quickly do you learn
these things and then
do you only learn them after they
already went out of style i mean i'm
afraid i'm probably one of those people
who often learns these things only
after they've gone out of style but um
so i haven't learned what this
um uh this particular meme um
is about i suppose an interesting
question is whether
um if you um uh
to what extent gosh i remember the
chapter invented the term meme
a chap called richard dawkins i remember
i don't think i've seen him since
the 1970s when he was just starting to
think about things like that term meme
i'm not sure whether
the thing he thought of as meme is
really the thing that has turned into
the memes
that we talk about today his his idea
was it's kind of
just like genes in in natural selection
and biology
sort of communicate attributes of an
organism to successive generations memes
communicate sort of fragments of
thoughts to
to successive uh groups of people um
anyway i think the um uh
okay so so the summary of this youtube
video is
the reporter in this video asks a kid a
question
and he says i like turtles at the 10
second mark
okay i completely don't get this um
and uh okay that's that's um that's good
i
i you know one of the things that is
sort of interesting in my
in my line of work i suppose is that uh
it's a you know i've learned a lot of
things in my life
and the um the thing that is always
notable is that
every day i'm dealing with things that i
don't know about
every day it's like oh my gosh how does
this work i have to try to learn this
how does it you know what what's going
on uh et cetera et cetera et cetera
and i think uh you know i i think a lot
of people
don't imagine that's that the way that
you know they imagine okay you go to
school you learn a bunch of stuff
and then you're set you don't have to
learn anymore um certainly for me
that is not the way it's worked and it's
not the way that i like it to work
and you know for example i've just
recently last few days i've been trying
to
piece together some aspects of the
history of mathematical logic
and i thought i understood that
reasonably well but i look at a bunch of
papers and it's like oh my gosh
i didn't realize this thing that doesn't
make sense
uh you know that couldn't possibly have
have come from this
you know how does that work etc etc etc
what is this
weird technical thing that i thought i
understood but i obviously don't
understand it
what does it mean and uh you know i
think it's a very um
uh it's really a very worthwhile thing
to kind of uh
you know keep learning stuff the other
the other big question which is
important when you try to make
decisions on the basis of things you
learned is do i actually understand that
do i know when i understand or do i
think i understand but i don't really
understand
and you know in in what i do for a
living of computational language design
it's kind of important to to know when
you really understand
because if you're going to do something
we say this is how our computational
language is going to work
um you know we've maintained
compatibility now across a third of a
century
in our language and so it's like we put
something in today
we better not make a mistake because
we're going to be stuck with it forever
and so it's then rather important to
know when you know what you're talking
about
and um i think something that i've
learned over the years
is you know what does it feel like when
i kind of know that i know what i'm
talking about
versus what does it feel like when i'm
still like a little bit uncertain
of you know i don't know what this is
about i don't know what's going on
um and uh you know can you distinguish
those two things
and um you know i think sometimes
sometimes in the modern education system
people are rushing so much you know
write another essay write another thing
do this test do it to time et cetera et
cetera et cetera
that people don't get used to this
feeling of yes i really understand
you know i really understand what's
going on there's real sort of you know
the foundations are on bedrock
and uh you know whatever you tell me
about this thing if you tell me
something different
i'm not going to be confused because i
really understand this and people don't
always get to that point and i think
that's a
a really useful point to get to and it's
also really useful to know
when you've got to that point and when
you're still kind of floating around on
sand
and where something could come along
where it's like oh i don't understand
that
um you know that's important when you're
trying to make these kind of
intellectual or technical decisions
of uh you know should we really do it
this way or that way
well i really understand i'm really
confident this way is going to work
or i don't really understand i'm not
sure
i don't know whether it should be this
way or that way let's try and find
something where we don't have to commit
to it being this way or that way
um the
okay so so someone's commenting about
this about this mystery meme
um uh that i get the meme because i'm
laughing
that it makes no sense okay
wow all right yeah
okay well clearly more for me to learn
that that's a good example of something
that i know i don't understand
and it's it's a it's a terrible thing
you know sometimes when we are
trying to uh find ways to you know
explain wolf and alpha
for for students or something and it's
like um
uh somebody will show me this is a you
know this is
uh sort of an ad we're gonna run in the
sidebar of orphan alpha or something
like that
about what we're doing or whatever else
and i look at it and it's got this cool
picture and so on
and i say i'm always a i'm always a
sucker for these pictures that have
weird animals and things in them and and
stuff like that and and things like
you know our spiky 3d logo with
sun hats and stuff like this i i always
think those are cute
um i don't know what other people do uh
but um the um uh you know it's it's
it's a little bit um a little bit i kind
of know
it's like this is something that is
intended to communicate
to people who are much younger than me
and who understand all these memes and
things
i don't understand this don't ask an old
foggy like me
about this question because i have no
idea whether people will think this is
cool campy crazy or incomprehensible
um and uh that that's um so people can
can comment on them uh you know we have
a whole line of um
uh a designer in our in our art
department
at some point started designing these
wolves
that um a kind of uh the wolfy symbol
that um uh
get used for various kinds of um uh
various kinds of things related to our
products
like there's one that for some reason i
started calling the butler wolf
which is a a wolf dressed up in a kind
of uh tail coat with a top hat and
things that's a kind of a
welcoming wolf that appears on some of
our
uh um kind of introductory documentation
type stuff
so you know it's a good question whether
that i think it's amusing
i think it's kind of cool but i don't
know whether other people do or not
hard to tell i mean it's uh the the
always
when you're doing user interface design
for computers these days
uh one of the things that people will
sometimes say is
uh you know that's like clippy and
that's not a term of respect um uh
for people who who don't remember don't
know this this is from uh from a while
ago in
in windows the um uh
uh there was this kind of um helper icon
that was this helpful paper clip with uh
it's kind of personified paperclip with
eyes and things and it would
it would uh you know blink at you and
all that kind of thing
and it would um uh where the paper clip
would come up
and make a helpful comment or what it
thought was over
or its programmers thought was a helpful
comment when you're using windows
and people didn't like clippy
they thought clippy was was well they
somehow they just hated clippy and um i
remember that
i thought clippy was cute i thought
clippy was i didn't think it was
particularly useful
it didn't really work quite well enough
it didn't quite have the right things to
say at the right time
but i thought it was really cute and i
remember for example when you would
print
things the the the printer version of
clippy was this kind of paper clip
that was undulating like it was kind of
going through
a piece of paper going through a printer
either it was all really cute
but um uh you know to prove that one
doesn't necessarily know what other
people are going to find
cute or not people generally hated
clippy
um and possibly as i say because of the
functionality rather than because of the
the graphic design but when one's doing
user interface design in particular
woman's doing this kind of
let me assist you as a user and
providing this kind of um
uh you know uh thing that that um
is an assistive thing um
you know a common kind of user interface
comment is you know
make sure it isn't like clippy uh well
our wolves aren't animated so we're not
like clippy there
all right i better wrap up uh before i
say anything too silly
um anything anything more silly
about these kinds of topics so all right
well thanks for
thanks for joining us and um um
look forward to seeing you on another
live stream
bye for now